Aloha everyone thank you for singing
to me this is called the perfect the
perfect JavaScript library because in
JavaScript tooling because it's
obviously highly subjective right like
these are my natural naturally my own
opinions about what we should choose but
it's the talk that I wish I would have
heard three four years ago I first
started building out JavaScript
libraries because libraries have vastly
different concerns than apps that we
build for users so these are the
learnings that I've kind of picked up
over time building tooling type things
both an open source on the job as
watching other people and seeing what
they did in order to build their
libraries
so I've already tweeted up link to the
slides if you want to follow along I'm
going to have tons of resources and
links to other things that I can't deep
dive into so if you go to my Twitter
been MVP you should already see a tweet
there so whenever we're talking about
non end user features like building up
tooling we need to ask ourselves like
what's the benefit of all this like do
these decisions that we're going to do
they really really matter because if
it's not a feature for the end user then
it needs to be a feature for the
developer so that they can then give
value to the end user otherwise we find
ourselves bike shedding and arguing over
things that really don't matter so this
article by Kent C Dodds that basically
says exactly that it says basically we
need to measure our success how well we
can deliver what the end user wants
therefore our choice of tooling should
be based upon that goal and nothing else
so then as a result our kind of focused
on the user mentality it still applies
for the tooling of libraries except that
the user in this case or other
developers those developers that are
going to build things use our library
and their apps for other users so
instead about
think about how we should write the code
in this talk Malta already talked
already covered some of that stuff we're
going to focus on everything else that's
related to the library and to the repo
so everything that enables developers to
build user experiences using our library
but first can I get everyone to stand up
real quick I'm gonna get everyone to
stand up I know we're about to have
lunch and such so what I like to do and
the beginning of my talks is to have
everybody do 10 squats together just
like this okay so it's just something to
have fun you know if you don't want to
you could totally sit down and not do it
you could just move your arms or
whatever but something to get the blood
flowing right before we have lunch so we
can you know have more space to have
lunch so let's do the Tin Tin squats
together we'll start with zero okay
because it's JavaScript right and we'll
count out together here we go ready zero
yeah that's weird one two three nice
nice four I think we're halfway yep five
six almost there seven yes eight nine oh
yeah that's it okay all right
obviously everyone have a seat nicely
done nicely done okay so just to
formally introduce myself my name is
Benna leg to do I'm a Christian a
husband and a father this is my family
right here it's my wife Rashida
we've been married nine years we'll be
10 years in September our oldest
daughter Simone she will be six next
month our middle daughter Avery next to
me she is three and a half and then our
youngest son Asher who's looking very
confused in this picture he turned one
last year so we live in the San
Francisco Bay Area in a small town
called Pittsburgh not to be confused
with Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
but it's Pittsburgh California and I'm
also a Google developer expert
Microsoft MVP both in web technologies
so as you might have guessed for my
t-shirt I work at stitch fix I'm a
principal front-end engineer there for
those of you who haven't heard of stitch
fix it's an online personal styling
service so basically take the bird out
of shopping so that you can get quality
clothes for yourselves so we combine
technology data science with actual real
human stylists in order to bring you
awesome clothes oh I want to mention
that we're three right
our headquarters is in San Francisco but
we have a huge remote culture so we have
engineers throughout the whole country
in fact to my colleagues James and
Nathan are Nolan are here here at the
conference they're actually way in the
back there so it's my first time getting
to see them in person except not on blue
jeans so that will be super fun
so anyway enough about me let's talk
about building this perfect javascript
library right so the the info applies
whether you're creating an open-source
library or even an internal library
within your your company so remember
we're shifting our focus to what the
users our developers need not what we
particularly care about okay
so let's jump right in the first thing
that I suggest that we need is we need
helpful Docs bucks that explain how to
install the library
examples of use the library and and then
once you finally figure out how the
library works a full API spec so the
question for us then is what makes it
possible to have helpful ducks well my
suggestion is that we write the docs
before the implementation why because
writing good Docs is actually really
hard so writing the docs beforehand
makes it a little bit easier I suggest
because one we're more likely to have
cohesive
DOX if we write it all up front the
formatting of the docs the inclusion of
examples if they'll all be consistent to
all be the same and then secondly when
we write the docs when we know ahead of
time we know about how the library works
the least right so we're able to have
empathy for newcomers which was also
what malted mentioned in this talk as
well
and then lastly number three we can get
feedback from theirs before we do the
implementation and we'll be able to just
give them the docs in the format that
anybody using the library would read
them so that they'll be able to really
understand how how things work and it's
much better than trying to give them
give them an implementation spec so then
the question is like what kind of Docs
should you write I want you to keep in
mind that they're at least four types of
Docs there are tutorials there how to
guys explanations and references so if
I'm using lodash as an example
references would be the traditional API
Docs for lo - how two guys would be
example showing common use cases for lo
- functions like pick for instance
explanations on the other hand our blogs
videos talks at conferences to explain
maybe why using lodash chain is poor
performing there so they're really
opinionated in their topic and it's
stuff that you wouldn't necessarily put
in API Docs and then tutorials would be
low - workshops that we'd find on
egghead or front-end masters online to
help guide the user step-by-step so for
your perfect library you should at least
have references and how-to guides so the
API Docs and the examples so in summary
for the docs my suggestion for your
repose read me md file is to have things
in this order write badges description
installation quick guide then the API
technical details contributing and
license and I want to call out that the
technical details should be at the
bottom right usually the library gets
created because they want to solve some
kind of technical problem make something
faster or make something better so it
gets put at the top of the readme and
it's like paragraphs and paragraphs and
nobody wants to read that stuff only you
care about that stuff
so put that at the bottom and you know
show me how to install your library ok
so then with helpful Doc's I'm now able
to use your library write and develop
but then the next thing that I would
need is I would need typescript types so
for those who don't know typescript is a
type superset of JavaScript that
compiles down to plain JavaScript though
this suggestion may be a little bit
controversial right it's certainly my
own bias because I love using typescript
but the numbers from the state of
JavaScript
Servais kind of backed me up typescript
has become super duper popular in 2018 I
consider it the year that everyone
discovered typescript right so only a
third of people in 2017 were using
typescript then the number jumped to
almost half in 2018 and then last year
it was nearly 60% of people using
typescript and when you add in all
people who want to learn how to use
typescript the number jumps to 80% so
that means 8 out of every 10 developers
will need typescript definitions from
your library in order to develop in
typescript so then the question is what
makes it possible to make typescript
definitions available to the developers
well one option is you could build your
app build your library rather in
JavaScript regular JavaScript and then
add typescript definitions too
definitely typed it's this repo of high
quality
typescript definitions so they're like
7,000 typescript definite in that repo
react is in their lo dashes in their
various different libraries that are
written that are not written in
typescript but have typescript types
available
the only drawback or one of the
drawbacks with this really is that you
have to know typescript really well in
order to create typescript definitions
so my suggestion is you just might as
well write it in typescript right
there's definitely a learning curve with
using typescript no doubt but in the
interest of serving your users the other
developers who want to use your library
writing in typescript is the best way to
provide type definition files because
they're going to get auto-generated and
I'll talk a little bit later about about
how that happens it's also really
difficult to write types for untyped
code because when we have untyped code
we're able to make some shortcuts and
assumptions about how things work but
those things aren't allowed and
typescript because we have to be type
safe so typescript also in addition
gives us modern JavaScript so all of the
nice features that are coming out and
new versions of Okuma script those are
also available in typescript so it not
only a win because we give type
definitions to our users but we also get
to develop with matcha it's kind of
everybody's winning in that sense all
right so now let's get a little bit
tactical here so now I know how to use
your Lib because you gave me helpful
docs I you provided typescript
definitions because you wrote in
typescript so now I'm good I can just
build my app and continue to use your
awesome library but while developing
there's nothing more frustrating than
running into a library bug right and in
the beginning you know we're trusting we
assume the libraries
perfect so the problem is with us so
we're spending hours and hours wondering
why you know I'm giving all this
information are providing the parameters
that the library says and those helpful
Docs and I'm not getting the help the
answer that I was supposed to like
what's going on
so we really want our library to be
perfect like bug free we need to do our
absolute best to make sure that there
are no bugs so then the question of
course is like what do we have to do in
order to make our library as bug free as
possible well it starts with the
three-headed monster of unit test
testing with coverage from jest linting
from es lint and then type checking from
typescript so I want to call out the
type checking because not only is
developing an typescript
like good for providing type definitions
like we talked about it's also good
because it helps ru it's also good for
our users because it helps to prevent
bugs so those like edge cases where
something was undefined when you didn't
expect it to be undefined or you were
factor a function but forget to change
one of the places where you called it
like typescript will catch all of those
different things and with Visual Studio
code you can get type checking happening
as you're coding so you're like fixing
problems or catching problems as you're
coding but I'm guessing most of you knew
that already
what I'm more interested in is taking it
to a kind of a next level so typically
you would run linting and type checking
and unit testing with three separate
commands like I mentioned but with a
feature ingest called Jeff's projects
you can run them all through just so
gest has been a refactored maybe a year
ago into a platform so in the beginning
you have what I call the file collector
and that determines like what files
should be run in order to be tested and
then at the end part have what I call
the error reporter that
shows what errors happened and what
passed and all those things and then in
the middle there's the runner which is
the actual thing we're running so
typically that's just been a unit test
runner in the middle but now you can
have different plugins to run other
things so you can have an es Lindt
runner or you can have a TS c a
typescript compiler runner in the middle
so what now when you use that set of
thing now you can have es Lindt run in
watch mode which is not possible with
the es let command-line because just
runs in in wash watch mode you can also
run all of the things in parallel as
well because that's how just runs and
then you get a consistent error
reporting at the end about which things
failed so simply you call just drop your
test script in your npm script and
you're off to the races and everything
will be tested there and then you can
take that test script and you can run it
in your CI or your continuous
integration environment so there are
many CI services out there like Travis
or circle CI but lately I have been
using github actions and github
workflows and and really really loving
it because I can just use git up
github actions and not have to sign up
for a different service and connect it
to my repo so here's an example of a
github workflow that runs the tests on
no 10 on no 12 and 13 so whenever I'm
running my tests part of it is I run it
on all the LTS versions so that'll be
ten and twelve the even numbers because
eight just got dropped and then I run it
on the latest odd to see if there are
any new things backwards-compatible
changes that I got it kind of catch as
quickly as possible
so it's important to run on multiple
versions of node for your library
because you don't know which versions
your developers are going to use so I
really want to spend more time unpacking
some of those things that I talked about
but I don't
time to go into those details so here
are a bunch of links to resources that
kind of go more into those all right so
we've discussed helpful Docs we talked
about typescript types and then how our
library could be bug free let's bring it
home with the last one so no matter how
hard you test and test and test there
are inevitably be bugs you know we're
still gonna be bugs no matter how well
we write our code so or even if you
write perfect code they're still gonna
be a feature request from someone that's
a really good idea that you want to
implement so you want to be able changes
out to your users out to those
developers as quickly as possible so
from their initial request to when it's
published on the registry we want to
make that as quick as possible so the
question for us is like what makes those
changes get there as quickly as possible
the first it starts with the issue
itself okay whether it's a bug or a
feature request we want is money as much
in detail as possible so with github
issue templates you can guide the
developer into a flow based upon their
need so whether it's a bug report or a
feature request and then with each of
those templates you can have labels tied
to them so things are automatically
categorized for you when you're
filtering through different problems and
one thing I do want to call out is
specifically for bugs you can suggest
that the developers and run the end info
package and include its results and it
provides all this information about
their environment so whether they're
Windows or Mac or you know what versions
of node and yarn and NPM they have
installed and there's plenty of other
things in the CLI that you can configure
so you can go to their helpful Docs and
find out more about it but it kind of
just answers a lot of the questions from
the start ok so there are various
communication files to streamline the
process thank you very much
so I want to call out the prettier
config file especially if you're not
familiar with prettier it provides
consistent formatting to all of your
files JavaScript CSS like markdown files
everything so now there's no time wasted
arguing over the format of your code but
it also makes development super fast
because you no longer have to think
about formatting your code just if you
have an editor that automatically
formats unsaved or on paste or whenever
your code gets formatted so you don't
have to spend time you know adding a new
line and then tabbing in three times and
moving the curly brace like it'll do all
that stuff for you in fact if you're
starting out with the library there are
a couple of scripts that you can run as
a way to just kind of bootstrap your
library so you can run the license
package to give you whatever license you
want and that becomes your license that
MD you can run the git ignore package
and I'll give you a good ignore based
upon your environment most likely node
you can generate a code of conduct with
the cough gin or Cove gin package then
you run goodd in it you run NPM in it
and you're off to the races there so
then after the code is written the PR
passes it gets merged into master or
whatever your release branch is we need
to get that code out to the registry as
soon as possible so the first step is
ensuring that we're generating the
actual target formats module formats so
that they can be consumed by the
developers app so these days for modern
j/s I suggest two formats
that's Atma script module format or ESM
mainly for tree shaking and then
commonjs or CJ s which is for a lot of
the standard node of applications so
first you have the main field that's for
your CJ s endpoint then you want to have
the module and J s next
properties that's the entry point for
ESM and then there's also the side
effects property that webpack uses for
Atma script modules as well I have a
link a resource that explains the neset
then necessary the need for that then
you have the type field that points to
your type script definitions there that
we talked about in part two you have the
files field that points to where the
built files are located and we use that
instead of using NPM ignore which is
what's traditionally used and I have an
article that explains why that is and
then now we use babel to transpile our
typescript into vanilla Jas so both the
ESM and the CJ s targets you just use a
typescript plug-in in order to do it and
then we use TSC TSC the typescript
compiler to build the typescript
definitions and lastly wrap it all up
into a nice build script that can be run
to run all of those together and then
with that build script in place we can
achieve continuous delivery or the CD
side of CIN CD so first we run the build
to generate all those files and then
secondly we use a package called
semantic reliefs to actually release to
the package registry so it's meant to be
executed in your CI environment after
every successful build to your release
branch most likely master so it makes
releases what they say unromantic and
unsentimental so the cool thing about
this is that I can merge a PR for my
library from my phone and it gets
automatically released to NPM within
five minutes like I don't have to be on
my computer and do a NPM version and
push something out like it all happens
inside of CI which is pretty cool and
then lastly you should probably verify
that what she released was actually good
so you can use unpackage or je s deliver
or even on NPM they have this new
Explorer tab to browse your package to
make sure all the files were there so
here are all the resources that I was
alluding to as I was going on please get
the slides and check those out to click
through ok
whoo ok that was a lot of stuff right
and chances are that you probably missed
something when you're responding to that
slack message right I know some of you
are doing it I can see some of you are
doing it ok but let's quickly recap but
instead of going it by user need I'm
gonna group it by what we care about now
so we can be a little bit selfish now so
and we'll see that the what makes up a
perfect library a perfect repo is a mix
of communication tools as well as
technical things just like the perfect
developer is a mix of technical skills
and communication skills I'm not gonna
spend time talking about 10x or nothing
nothing like that ok so here we go this
is everything on one slide so you have
your development experience that starts
with being able to write modern j/s and
if you're using a nice editor like PS
code prettier es LAN type chucking
happens while you develop then we have
testing and continuous integration I
suggest using github actions and running
just as a platform so everything works
together for building and continuous
delivery we use babble for transpiling
typescript for type definitions and then
a whole bunch of fields in your package
JSON in order to use semantic release
and release automatically and then
lastly there are a bunch of reef repo
files as I call it that are basically
all around communication and allowing
the developers ease and using your
library so that was all the info that I
needed like three or four years ago and
when I was trying to build my first
library and I was trying to do it the
correct way from the beginning but to be
honest I probably would have been too
overwhelmed at that point like I counted
in that previous slide like 20 different
suggestions that I had in order to build
that perfect repo and at that time even
though I wanted to do it right I was
more focused on actually building the
library itself not all this tooling
infrastructure because I didn't care
about it then as much as I care about it
now and even now like I don't want to go
through all those 20 things every time
I'm building a library so I created this
zero config CLI tool I call it
Bennett in VP CLI after myself yes and
it abstract all of that work for all the
libraries that I'm building so it does
everything but write the docs and
obviously the source code should write
the source code that would be amazing
but it's not it's not sentient yet okay
so the CLI does have some options right
so you could totally use it for your
library but it's called the bit MVP CLI
for a reason it's for me and for my
library so you know I'm not gonna accept
any issue tickets to make it more
configurable I'm just telling you right
now that's not going to happen
so if it works kind of like a react
scripts if you ever have used that
before if with create react app you can
run NPM been MVP CLI create with the
name of your library and it will create
the whole folder all the github
workflows all the templates package.json
with all the fields and then it installs
the package the CLI as a dependency so
that it could run all of the other
scripts as well so the test script and
the build script do basically what I
talked about before this dart script is
for development which basically runs
tests in watch mode so it just checks
whatever you've done and your get
changes and it will run the tests based
upon that changed code but the most
interesting thing which I really
really really wish I could spend more
time on as the integrate command and
basically what it does is it packages up
the library in a tarball
the same tarball that gets pushed up to
the registry but instead of pushing it
to the registry and you'll have a
separate app that it will install your
library into so you can install
something from a tar ball from the file
system and then I run tests and import
the library as if I was using it like a
application and I run tests that way to
make sure that like I exported all the
methods correctly my dev dependencies
and dependencies have been set up the
right way because sometimes I put them
in the wrong place so to make sure that
when developers using the library that
have everything that they need so if
you're interested in that you can check
check out the library and lastly the CLI
uses itself for development and testing
and building so it's kind of like the
original perfect library that's enabling
other perfect libraries to be created so
one last thing friend of mine Jonathan
creamer he is really passionate about
front-end tooling as am I so he's
wanting to create this community around
front-end tooling he's coined the term
div ops instead of DevOps for this type
of thing so he has a blog about it and
there's a slack group and there's a
subreddit that you can join for that
okay so that's it
I just flooded you with all this
information I want to remind you that
the slides I tweeted out a link to the
slide so you can totally follow it there
hopefully there's stuff that you learned
right there's also likely stuff that I
forgotten so I welcome your feedback to
tell me some things that could be added
to make it even better I want to thank
the conference the conference organizers
for inviting me to share my knowledge
with all of you and I want to thank you
all too for coming to the talk because
you know the hallway track is real like
you could have been there you know you
could have gone to get ahead
start on lunch like some people have
done you can't see them but I totally
can see them but it's okay I'm not hurt
at all
and it's Hawaii right so you could
totally be anywhere else but here but
you're still here so I really really
appreciate it so if you've got any
questions feel free to find me
afterwards
I have swag that I'm givin away like
this hat so I'll give that out or if
you're introverted you can ping me on
Twitter so thank you very much enjoy the
rest of the conference in Mahalo
[Applause]